ces radars sont les yeux du canada son
article depuis la fin des années 80 leur
technologie est dépassée la mise à
niveau de nos infrastructures
est plus urgente que jamais ottawa va
dépenser 4,9 milliards de dollars pour
déployer un nouveau système de radar qui
sera relié à un système de surveillance
par satellite et un réseau de capteurs
sous murray notamment
et pour accélérer la réponse à toute
forme d'intrusion désert ou de la mer
les centres de contrôle seront aussi à
la fine pointe de la technologie
le monde a changé le 24 février dernier
avec l'invasion russe en ukraine dit la
ministre la menace sur l'arctique ou ci
répond le commandant adjoint du norad
nous demeurons concerné par l'évolution
de la menace principalement l'évolution
la menace qui est présenté par
l'émission de croisière excentrant
développement et qui sont prises en main
dans l'inventaire de nos compétiteurs
dès le début de la gare déjà la
population s'inquiétait pour la sécurité
canadiens attendu depuis longtemps
l'annoncent n'étonne pas pas plus que le
moment choisi pour la faire chacun s'est
mis à regarder ces vulnérabilités chacun
soumis à voir en quoi la russie pourrait
importer atteinte à ses intérêts à
partir du moment où on doit avoir une
protection en l'épaulant l'affaiblissent
du plan de modernisation selon
l'opposition conservatrice c'est la
réticence du gouvernement à participer
au bouclier antimissile américaine on
pourrait a défendu alors que les
américains ont été par les américains
ont dit on va se protéger en premier en
versant protéger les pressions vont être
certainement grande pour le nageur à la
retraite richard blanchette le bouclier
antimissile devra être la prochaine
étape si le canada veut vraiment assuré
sa souveraineté dans le nord il faut
vraiment qu'il y ait une bonne
coopération entre les états unis et au
canada si on veut que la défense le
norad soit aussi efficace que possible
la ministre rappelle qu'il s'agit du
plan de modernisation le plus ambitieux
des quatre dernières décennies mais pour
le moment ottawa donne peu détail tant
sur les systèmes qui remplaceront les
anciennes installations que sur
l'échéancier de leur mise en service et
si valérie gamache radio canada ottawa